Oh squ a little bit a little bit yeah
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my mom plays five nights
at Freddy's hi everybody my name is what
is it mama mama plug mom apply actually
you could say your real name I'll give
you the option
please don't make everyone assume that
I'm forcing you to call yourself mom
apply no no no I'm very comfortable yeah
okay so do you know how to play this
game I have no idea but you've seen me
play maybe million times yeah okay so
there is a walking teddy bear by the
name of Franco Fontbonne and he is
haunting a Chinese buffet
you just got hired as a security guard
let me do that whoopee-doo whoo oh
you're not happy about that
mmm saucy okay so it's 12 a.m. on the
first night okay so you need to listen
very closely he's going to give you
instructions and you need to listen very
closely nothing no learning my character
here no one would be gonna make my money
at night
so now you're in charge so what do you
gather from what he was saying to you ah
you think they're gonna try to make
something I don't want to be wasn't care
of me
yeah something like that they're gonna
make you something you don't want to be
this that's pretty much the long and the
short of exec yeah I'm looking at them
but nobody do you see where you are
um oh uh oh I'm here yeah okay ooh
camera thobey you almost had him dad
what yeah
how about here ya go hmm nothing there
well what am I looking for you're
looking for them
Oh your animatronics their life oh
they're I it's questionable whether
they're alive or not what do I hear
something different there yeah dum dum
dum I heard that oh yeah well that's
Freddy he likes to sing and also there's
another there's three animatronics in
total is Franco Janko and Blancos okay
you got to make sure you watch out for
Banco he's a tricky one okay okay
oh I'm little scared some visitin boys
are full in I have to go until 6:00 why
am i yes oh my gosh you know suddenly
I'm very very scared I know right
oh yeah Banco is gonna sneak up behind
you watch out for Chango Oh No Franco's
the worst of them all come on where are
you yeah where are they he's actually I
will I what you wanna know something
spooky well you've looked at two of them
where I know right you've seen two of
them I've seen right yeah
oh yeah that's a poster yeah okay what
about one B what about me okay just one
hey you ready ready
not quite is enough ready I might be
Freddy actually I think that's Freddy
yeah I look closely yeah right so what
is it doing here Oh is he yeah this is
relaxing you know
it's out a good time what's here people
I don't know
I remember so what would where should I
go oh you know around just look around
yeah
who's that is it Riley we can't all be
Freddie I don't know they look all I
could me they look all alike
I have no Oh what is that last eat
that's the one what is this what do you
think what's is what's that one's name
chica chunko chunko chunko chunko yeah
okay you want to save your power is the
thing power you I have a 19% yeah 18%
you did it you on the game you're the
best
you did it congratulations up here's the
second night okay there's another night
all right
it's gonna get even harder now Oh masa
pie piece of pie
I hear something I better watch
carefully I don't care
nobody's here I'm there all night seeing
you they're all looking at me looking at
you
yeah uh yeah I knew you were dead a
while ago you remember how when you
tried to push the light on the left side
it wouldn't work yeah Emmons I stay yeah
yeah then it was too late it continued
ah let's watch carefully you gotta watch
look they don't kill us okay
they move you gotta you got a are
mindful of these I am I am copy on it's
a one-way where are you I'm watching you
oh no they're all on stage right now
were they looking at you oh yes look at
that ooh dad looks spooky okay nobody's
here over there three I hear dump dump
dump about six would be sittin right
here I I hear I opossum hangers in the
kitchen why oh she will not use
something she's hungry yeah ooh ooh I
hear cranking cranking oh she likes to
eat somebody looking for pizza left over
uh-huh it's an idiot check your leg okay
three two huh don't don't don't come
sneak on me sneak on her check to be
don't eat oh um you don't look so good
yeah what happened oh okay check your
door lights there's no one standing on
the lawn they're right here right here
oh yeah yeah
took that woo gonna remember if you
don't know where they are on the camera
Mona you might want to check oh I see
her she's in the top right I see yeah oh
oh now she's near the bathroom after eat
ooh what should I do
hmm why would she be in the bathroom
after eating because she ate too much
that the cool party I'm here I'm here
okay you're getting full oh she's coming
down the hall hey yeah she thankful
enough oh come on you live one more meal
I thought you had already bunch of
leftover pizza come on
do I look like a PITA oh I'm watching
you you watching oh my goodness what
should I do
I know she's not that close yet but when
she gets to 4b you weren't watching you
weren't watching you were so focused on
chica you've got the left side Freddy
Freddy Freddy got me no I know Freddy
sneak on Freddy likes to sneak off
meeting you or try you are sneaky bad
I'm getting raw not new game continue
yeah my just one more try that Freddy
I'm too old for this you get one more
try and then we'll give you your poor
old heart of rush oh gee and you're good
doing great
Kizer okay now focused stay true mmm
chunko likes the right side Freddy likes
the left side from the Buddy here yeah
it's him nobody I know
okay party time nobody here oh I'm
watching you guys don't you dare don't
you dare come near me like that oh
they're gonna sneak on you no no no no
not you better not I'm watching you I'm
watching you well okay it's not here
feels good
all right I think I think are they gone
I think freddie has left the stage
well maybe Freddie scared me too yeah
I'm scared it's good it's good I think
that'll works
yeah not only what do you do do you know
the one for you
I don't like the old finger it was all
right so you might wanna you might want
to look out yeah I think they're coming
for you oh oh
those lights check those lights oh okay
I'm gonna go here look Boop I'm not
there amazingly well I'm gonna scare
them before this give the good stress
yes my terror see a guy like it yeah I
watched your video million times knowing
is gonna work Oh mmm chunk oh hello
hello hello remember the left side light
right I'm gonna scare them my god oh my
goodness ready
check those lights it hey come on
look check that left siding and I think
they might have gotten close are you
sure yeah
Boop that's not check it to be hey
what's going to okay what about 4b I was
going to okay you know how to play this
game I'm a spurt expert ooh good why you
who are you who are you what are you
doing dear
Oh No I've always wondered that why does
he go into the supply closet I don't
know boom Oh nobody here what's going on
Oh No okay
see see mommy plier very scary right
I know yeah yeah to be oh hello
just keep an eye on him oh just watch
him right it was him if he moves from
there check your life now okay so now
don't open the door but check the light
one more time good don't open the door
he's still there you see that shadow
shadow okay what should I know you
should uh wait until the leaves to go
check the light again he might be gone
oh oh yeah he's gone okay now you can
open the door yeah you can open it
yeah you guys close enough yeah turn off
the light no no close don't lose it yeah
you're running low on power
well [ __ ] that's okay Oh 25% you are
your 3 a.m. you got 25% that's not the
best that's not that's not good oh my
goodness what I'm gonna do I don't know
I just want to hide somewhere check your
lights
here door door
elisee just a staring at me yeah tell me
not killing what about the other side
did you check the other life I know I
haven't you didn't did you
don't you dare night Oh was the door
closing off hey hey
light off oh yeah that's a problem
that's you kinda yeah as chica what
should I do
nothing you can do I'm a mommy plier go
away
special authority in this game since I'm
the king the final clue oh you just ran
out of power
oh no move your camera over to the left
side
ah here someone's very upset because
you've been calling Bonnie Freddy this
whole time Oh someone is mad at you
a real Freddy it's so bad of you
[Music]
it was a senior song
I don't like this okay
okay Joe what what I mean look you did
it you die Tom you down well you didn't
want whoa I need the bubbles you uh you
didn't survive but you did good you were
catching on very quickly I was million
tops up with people you tsunami right
now you're doing pretty good action oh I
gotta admit you were doing pretty good I
need to take a medication all night
dinner oh wait you guys say goodbye oh
boy alright so thank you everybody so
much for watching grooving
my mom plays five nights at Freddy's I'm
watching minions time but first time I
ever played yeah so even though she was
naming everything absolutely wrong I'm
bad at nature you were doing pretty good
you were okay you were alright you don't
bring it up bring it I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you you did okay so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
thank you mom for joining me
hey last words of wisdom Oh fun fun
happy you're here alright hey and thank
you again and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye-bye